i want to talk to you guys about uh the
leftists in this country and we'll segue
into that we got the story from mashable
oh man anti-work subreddit goes private
after rough fox news interview yikes
saith mashable
i would like to introduce you to a
subreddit called anti-work
my understanding after uh some cursory
research is that the point of this forum
was it was people who thought no one
should have to have a job
you should be allowed to get food
shelter and whatever given to you
without doing any work
it started to grow rapidly 1.7 million
followers of this subreddit is formed
it quickly changed however into a work
reform where it was like hey we just
want rights we want to do work but we
got to get paid better
sure now ultimately i think this message
is co-opted by the left and that's what
poisoned it but here's what happens
fox news reaches out to interview one of
them someone from the the form of 1.7
million people who don't want to work or
who don't like working
and
my so this is what i read basically
someone they all held a poll where they
said okay should we do this everyone
voted the majority said do not go on fox
news oh boy one of the moderators
decided to go on fox news anyway
it was a um
autistic non-binary individual i believe
who appeared on fox news wouldn't look
directly into the camera and was shying
away in a messy room with an
inarticulate message that seemed
wishy-washy
saying things like i have to walk dogs
25 hours a week and i shouldn't have to
do that to be able to eat and survive
and i think probably that was more
articulate than the person was this
caused brigading people rushing into the
subreddit and then ultimately it shut
down now they're saying they may come
back but what i find fascinating this
whole story
the anti-work movement
the rapid explosive spread fox news
covered this from you know only a year
ago to you know tens of thousands of
followers to 1.7 million
you go to the subreddit these are people
who are outright saying you know i
shouldn't have to have a job
this is the mentality of the modern left
so i'll warn i will first say a lot of
the work reform arguments from any of
these people many of them leftists i
completely agree with someone takes out
20 grand in school loans now they owe
100 because of interest and i'm like
okay that i can understand is a problem
if you take out a loan for 20 grand and
there's some interest on it i can
recognize you know you got to pay it
back and you got to pay back the
interest but when it's when it's massive
and that's for a lot of people then i'm
basically like yo the system is corrupt
we got to shut that down i can respect
that but when you come out and say
things like and
i shouldn't have to do any work i should
just get stuff
i'm like which slave
you know will you be
which person will you be enslaving which
group of people in order to have them do
the work to make your food because food
doesn't come from nowhere
i mean even when it grows on the trees
someone's still gotta go get it for you
exactly no such thing as free lunch and
every single thing you have that you
didn't work for somebody worked for
without having and sometimes that's fine
because it's voluntary somebody gave the
charity they wanted to help you and then
sometimes that's not
fine because it was forcibly taken from
the person when you yourself could have
been earning money it's interesting how
our conception of work has changed
over the past 100 years maybe even just
the past 50 years but people used to see
their job as something that gave them
meaning and they no longer do and there
are a lot of reasons for that and i'm
not just blaming workers themselves for
having this attitude i think in many
respects the working class are not
treated well i don't think the left has
done a great job representing them
historically and i think that they need
people who are willing to fight for them
who actually have some level of contact
with them and don't despise them and
their values which they don't right now
but
ultimately people used to conceive of
their work as that which they
contributed and that which they were
adding and now we have this idea that
there are certain jobs that are worth
doing because what is being done at
those jobs is valuable and then
basically every other job is pointless
and it's humiliating to have to do it
but the reality is there's dignity in
all work and yes workers should be
treated with more dignity i agree with
that completely but the idea that well
there are just certain jobs nobody
should have to do is absurd because all
of those jobs need doing so what you
should be saying is respect the people
doing it you shouldn't be saying i
shouldn't have to work to survive it's
insane there's a meme that i saw that i
think sums up a lot of the culture war
it was my brother posted it it said
people who are unvaccinated and oppose
the vaccines
don't want you to get it because they're
scared you could die
the people who are vaccinated and want
you to get it are scared they could die
and regardless of the vaccine opi i'm
not asserting anything about vaccines
just it's just a meme yeah it's just
interesting that there's this
perspective of oh no
i don't want you to be hurt and the
other perspective is you better do this
so i don't get hurt yeah i bring that up
because and always talk to your doctor
about private medical decisions but i
bring this up in this context because
what i see often from the left and like
the anti-worker community is i shouldn't
have to work and i should get stuff
and then my attitude is let me make as
much stuff as possible and then help
others with that stuff exactly well it's
so weird isn't it yeah and so i think
historically and again it's like this is
easy for me to say right because i
started a small business when i was 18
years old it turned out to be very
successful i get to do something that's
difficult at times but that i genuinely
love doing and there are a lot of people
who have jobs that are very difficult
they're not in the position that i'm in
and so i i totally understand that but
at the same time i'll hear people say
things like you know i have to work for
40 hours a week that's unnatural in the
past people used to take pride in the
fact that they were spending that amount
of time contributing right the problem
now is in this job economy that we've
found ourselves in the federal reserve
loves this they want two people and
they're like i don't have a job what do
i do
the federal reserve will be like well we
have an idea or whoever is in in control
you dig a hole and then you come over
and fill that hole back up once it's
done and we'll print a hundred thousand
dollars and then we'll give you 50 000
and you 50 000 but you're gonna have to
start paying us interest back on that
100 grand so they win they the more
money they can give out the winner the
more win they get so people are are
aware they've awakened to the
pointlessness of a lot of these jobs now
when you define work that's a scientific
word that means it's an energy transfer
in jewels it can be measured work we're
working right now if you're thinking
you're producing work what is the work
is it contributing to society that's
yeah so important and that's really
important because you sort of mention
these work projects and i've heard
people discuss this idea that yeah in
times of economic downturn what we
should be doing is creating these jobs
that we don't actually need so that we
can get people back in the workforce
and what that fails to take into account
is that the purpose of a job isn't
simply so that somebody can have
something to do all day the purpose of a
job is to find a way for a person to be
able to contribute to society at large
and it goes back to what we were
discussing earlier with these
discriminatory practices of only wanting
to hire someone on the basis of their
sex or skin color because what you're
basically saying at that point is we're
not interested in whether you're
qualified for the position because the
position doesn't exist for the people
you're supposed to serve in that role
the position exists for you to feel
special because you have that position
that is how we view work nowadays i'm
just going to leapfrog so much of this
conversation because i'm in my mind i'm
just like you know hopscotching through
all the points church that's where it
ends up church it's exactly community
people have no purpose yeah they have no
purpose so when they're complaining
about work it's because these jobs
aren't fulfilling to them yeah i feel
like they're wasting their times their
lives and their energy and they want to
do something else but they don't have
anything else either so they get
ideological yeah i'm not saying uh so i
just want to clarify too i'm not an
overtly religious person
but my point is that
when there was church there was
community and there was purpose for
people
and that's what people are lacking now
now that we're increasingly secular
country exactly and i'll add this and
also clarify in case there's any doubt
about this here um as i've mentioned
earlier i think the working class does
need to be treated better i think there
are so many jobs that we view as
indignant or beneath people and they're
not and part of the way we change that
is we really need to admire the people
who do those jobs because they're really
important and church is important here
because as a roman catholic at basically
every church that i've been to in my
adult life and particularly the the
latin mass that i've attended for the
past few years there is an intersection
of so many different people from various
economic classes and standings
and i don't think people have that
anymore because they don't have religion
when i think about the friends that i've
made through through my church and my
primary friend group basically all from
different income brackets i can't think
of any other social organization i'm a
part of where that's the case public
school and but i think but i think but
part of why i think that's really
helpful is because it does put you in
touch with like i'm i'm not only if i
wasn't going to that church if that
wasn't my faith community there i might
only be in touch with other people
working in artistic fields or doing
politics on the internet but instead i'm
in touch with people who are plumbers or
um
you know painters artists of a different
variety or work for a union we we should
create an award ceremony for trade jobs
so that we can highlight i'm half
kidding but you know we as a society we
we sports
athletes celebrities they get all of the
attention we have to give and then the
people who are actually making this
country work don't get any of it and
it's i think there's a spiritual
component you're right to say that but i
also think there's this elitism
as well that work is beneath me yes that
i shouldn't have to do this
and uh one of the arguments that's
always bothered me about immigration and
legal immigration is like they do the
jobs that america i do
i'm like well first of all there's
virtually no industry where immigrants
are the majority
and so americans are doing these jobs
and they're not beneath anybody to do
in fact many of our parents and
grandparents did jobs like this as well
and it wasn't beneath them yeah and they
they recognized that the work and the
money they ra they earned from that
help help
you know help provide for their families
which was the most important thing in
the world so they're elitists they're
torn from the world from the community
as you talk about spiritually
and there's this leftist contempt
generally for the
for the concept of work you go to the
anti-work subreddit what do you see
they're related subreddits are socialist
communist anarchist leftist anarchist
you look at the related subjects work
reform the communist fist is their
symbol
it's remarkable this this ideology that
that that infects these these these
forums when the issue is more to do with
uh you know what you can contribute the
just doing hard work rolling up your
sleeves it's not about anybody else it's
not about a grand ideology it's not
about someone ripping you off it's about
you valuing your valuing your life your
time your energy and what you do but all
of them just get infected by leftist
ideology then in comes the cultural
leftist ideology and then they implode
themselves yeah well and you know this
idea that there are jobs that americans
are unwilling to do i mean this is a
country where we have abortionists
pornographers prostitutes the idea that
there are just these jobs that are so
far beneath the dignity of americans and
what they're willing to accept is
ridiculous it is the case that there are
certain wages an american will not work
for and that is why they want to import
people to do those jobs here's the big
problem with the leftist ideology in
these subreddits is that they're doing
nothing to stop the mass wave of illegal
immigration that's right and so they're
wondering why it is you you bring up
there's wages they won't work for well
when you bring in to where we had two
million people entering this country on
without any any uh sense of where they
would go and how they will survive all
of a sudden now these college kids who
are looking for entry-level positions
they're not you're not you're not going
to get out of college and go work for a
firm you're going to get out of college
and go work for a starbucks something
while you try to figure things out maybe
find an internship but you're not gonna
be able to do that either because now
all of a sudden you're walking up and
you're seeing a huge line of people who
want work
so all of these entry-level positions
that you know they say the minimum wage
should be fifteen dollars an hour it
would be if the supply of low-skilled
labor was reduced well you know the
unions used to be opposed to mass
immigration if they were honest you if
there were well-run union unions who
were creative they'd be saying
okay
well if we're going to have a government
program that depresses wages meaning
mass immigration well we have to make up
for that with the with as you point out
with an increase in the minimum wage so
big corporations you can get your
immigrants but we get on our side
because we're subsidizing your labor
costs with a government program we get
to uh ensure that our employees and and
and union members get increased wages uh
if it's a major what if you raise the
the minimum wage only for large
corporations
they don't care that they wouldn't
surrounding errors but what would happen
is they couldn't hire but that's what
there's many people but more people
would be benefiting from working there
but they would still limit their ability
to higher mass they would just increase
the prices and it would have the same
effect on the on the local economy but
then people would buy their stuff
because their prices would go up that
didn't work that's that's that's that's
not even that's that's maybe partial
they hire less people to save them but
what they would do is the business
couldn't grow no no ian ian here's what
would happen
if you went to starbucks and said and
they and they do
increase minimum wage based on company
size as well in a lot of places like if
you have 50 or more employees or 150 but
here's what happens starbucks
uh well you know what let's not say
starbucks let's say
s bucks
uh uh just a word i made up seattle
bucks cafe will find a location where
there's a mom and pop cafe
they'll open up next door and
purposefully lose money with
ridiculously low prices you know why
because a regular person's gonna walk up
and they'll see mom and pop shop five
buck frappuccino and they're gonna look
over at starbucks four buck frappuccino
starbucks loses a dollar on every sale
but they're strangling yes the small
business who doesn't have the coffers to
fight back so if you came out and said
okay okay then we should raise the
minimum wage on these big you know these
bigger companies walmart's gonna sit
back with the cigar in their mouth and
be like
oh we can sink all of them
we're going to drop our prices because
we have billions upon billions in
profits we're going to take a 20 loss on
that store and we'll pay a minimum wage
and then once we eliminate all of the
local all the local shops local bakery's
gone local butcher shop is gone local
clothing store is gone then we're going
to crank the prices way up to
accommodate those sausages and you can't
do anything about that
inflated wages and reduce the the cost
of their sales i think that's a big risk
for a large corp that's a big risk no it
isn't i think it is in sustainability
cisco starbucks is across the street
from starbucks i'm not even kidding have
you guys seen this all over the place
there's literally a starbucks and a
crosstalk there was a starbucks inside
of a star no that was an onion article
no that was an onion article it sounds
true it might happen in chicago there
was one intersection where there's on on
the southwest corner starbucks in the
northeast corner of starbucks
they
they don't make money doing that they
dominate and take over bro these
corporations make so much in profits
with with all of these locations that
they can sacrifice one location to
defeat you the people the working class
oh so you think they'll lower the prices
at a specific location that's what they
do so if you know a local jurisdiction
says we're you know this our city is
increasing the minimum wage they'll say
okay
we will pay that
and then we're not going to raise prices
we're going to make sure our prices are
low enough that anyone who could compete
with us in an you know x mile radius is
is put out of business
then we can charge whatever we want
and they'll get their money back if if
you had to to an ignorant populace yeah
that would work people know yeah all the
time they do it all the time to a [ __ ]
in a pop an ignorant populace if people
knew what they were doing and that they
were trying to put businesses out of
business and they realized that they
didn't do that
this is why i said yesterday
you do but let i said this yesterday let
me know if you agree tom i said if you
went to your average american i don't
care if they're liberal conservative
otherwise and said
all of the good in your life your wages
the cheap gas everything we will allow
you to keep but we need you to sign this
document to kill a bunch of kids
overseas
i i say they would sign it i say the
average american would be like don't end
on just don't tell my friends i did
people walk up to this to starbucks
knowing exactly you know who they are
and what they do right i mean we just
went and bought a bunch of starbucks
because they got rid of the vaccine
mandate that's just wrote me in on this
one you did it tim yeah but that yeah i
stand by i stand by when a company does
the right thing i want them to do more
of the right thing so i'll call them out
now and it's not just about starbucks
because i you know look
i've only heard the anecdotes about
starbucks
now i was going to say like fact check
me on that i may be wrong
but yeah i don't know about it you know
why specifically but it is true that
businesses will intentionally take a
loss in order to destroy them can they
take the level of loss of having their
in their wages go up and their costs
their sales
depends on how much the change is in
either direction the quote nancy pelosi
when she's defending her individualized
stock trades that's capitalism yeah and
the challenge is that you may not like
it it's like how do you fix it and the
only way to fix it is through a
regulatory scheme
run by incompetence liars or lying
incompetence
so there's there's no good answer to
that if you don't you know i i sometimes
shop in places that aren't chain stores
because i know
i'm getting a little bit more customer
service and that's good and other times
i'll go to starbucks because i like the
coffee there yeah i got to be honest out
here even in west virginia the local uh
coffee and bagel shop has a mask mandate
by choice and the starbucks doesn't
drop that mandate dog you heard of here
first thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time